hey I'm with Kevin who I have just
realized reading tool I am yes yes we
stand in for a larger soup that doesn't
matter you've just seen the witcher 3 i
have for 45 minutes for 45 minutes okay
now I'm supposed to be a serious critic
you know yeah I'm a critic I'm supposed
to be yes some artiste but really what I
want to do is go oh my god the witcher 3
looks incredible and it's all i want to
talk about and i want to play it right
goddamn now give me this game it's been
like a runaway star for a couple of
years now yeah this has been announced I
mean it's people getting really really
excited for this one yeah but what's I
think what's really interesting about
this is is that you know they started
off by showing us a dense area showing
us that the biggest city in this
particular world and it looked really
great it was full of people but it was
also fairly fairly vast you know when
you think of say an elder scrolls City
you but I still think of something
that's sort of regimented looking this
looks like a place people actually live
where where things aren't lined up
exactly right and things are kind of
spread out a little bit but there are a
lot of people there and then and then we
traveled off into the countryside and we
got to see guralt interact with some of
the more spiritual aspects of this
universe he was on you know he's out
looking for this mysterious maiden who I
suspect is Siri from from the fiction
but he's out there and and you know he
interacts with this small goblin type
thing who lost its voice and then he
gets it back and it's all it's all very
funny and kind of annoying and cute and
you know he ends up interacting with
these three weird creepy women they come
out of a tapestry and he he you know he
goes off after werewolves and you know
the combat looks really fluid and fun
and he's got you know the five different
magical signs that I don't know there's
just there's so much going on and it
just covers so much space and it looks
like all that space is filled with
really interesting cool things to do
that I'm just I'm really impressed I
really want this game to be what it
looks like it's going
to be did they make sure in your 45
minutes slice that you've had a bit of a
bit of combat a bit of chatty a bit of
questing around a bit of riding around
doing things as they're little did you
get a little element of reach of the
things it was somewhat it was a little
less combat focus than last year's like
last year what they showed was very you
know choppy choppy and and really all
about the action this year they're
really you know they show the biggest
thing i think was just showing the
vastness of the world you know we quick
troweled he shows this mountain and he's
like you know that city we left a little
while ago it is 14 times further away
than that big mountain far off in that
distance and so you know there was just
this real sense of what the world isn't
how mysterious it is and how weird and
wonderful the things are out there it's
just I'm really excited I think they're
really making something special and if I
know you that kind of gameplay demo is
much more exciting to you than a shitton
a comeback right yes yes I just want to
see it all I want to see it all i'm i'm
excited i think this game is really
gonna be really i hope it's gonna be
awesome brilliant thank you Kevin my
pleasure